I get started with the last talk today
by Richard ping we will talk about
scalable algorithmic primitives for data
science is the mic working yes great ok
thanks for introduction David I'll be
talking about scalable algorithmic
primitives for data science just a bit
of a heads up that this is a a set of
new new slides and it does cover quite a
bit of material these are not things I'm
familiar with in fact what I learned
over the last two days is that there's a
lot of things I don't know about things
in English talk so if you have any
questions you're here to stop me
actually please stop me the later part
of this talk there it's actually fairly
time flexible to give any questions stop
me and ask and I'll be happy to go into
more details
so let me start off with a motivation
the motivating idea is that is the topic
I want to address in this talk quite a
few of them are motivated by several of
these problems that's because that's a
quite that become quite prevalent in
data science so these are things in
network science where you want to
measure the importance of edges in a
graph you want to partition or cluster
and network your image video processing
we saw a talk yesterday about taking the
pixel image and doing a low rank
factorization this is in general this is
things like the noising segmenting our
image this is mother key problem study
there in scientific computing there's a
lot of these kind of fairly large
measures that you want to do you want to
model physical forces you want to model
food simulation you want to model the
behavior of waves on them each of each
one of these is a fairly rich area on
its own so things like centrality there
is I mean each one of these that there
could be a separate talk on them but
what I want to kind of focus on is I
want to focus on some commonalities in
the ways that people have devised to
address these problems which is that
when we address these problems there
tend to be quite a few of these
primitives that we like to invoke so
this includes things like the backslash
command which solves a system of linear
equations includes things like solving a
convex optimization problem which are
networks gives you things like shortest
path or flows or this is one of the
things that use gets used a lot in
graphic compositions there's also
eigenvector SVD which says that of the
earlier talked about also got a cross
which is the idea that I want to compute
eigenvectors so there so the short the
short
takeaway is that there are several of
these commands that we like to invoke a
lot when dealing with these large-scale
data and I want to just start with one
of them so I'll start with the one that
I consider to be kind of the more
fundamental one which is the solving a
system of linear equations and I will
just appeal to reductions even though
this is not how you want to solve
optimization problem but I would like to
claim that if you can solve a system of
linear equations you can solve the
optimization problem and if you can
solve a system of linear equations by
things like inverse power method
you can get significantly faster I can
solve this as well and so this raises
the question of linear system as a augur
in a primitive and while we want to
think one of the recent developments is
that the data set has been getting
larger and larger so this has been
putting a lot of pressure on getting on
the performance of one of these linear
system solver primitives so especially
the backslash command in say MATLAB and
I think in julia is just the solve
command and i'd like to compare this
against one the probably the most
successful in a primitive which is
quicksort so in comparison i would like
to claim that there's a quite a bit of
discrepancy between our linear system
solver and things that we really think
of it as a burning primitive which is
quicksort
oh I'm being purposely ambiguous I will
get to about that like an iterative
method thing a bit so I'm just yeah
actually yeah here I'm using backslash
what I really should be saying is this
is our generic solve and the I just want
to compare against quicksort and these
are the kind of day the key traits that
I would like to mention which is that
first of all quicksort is a linear space
algorithm quicksort is parallelizable
actually quicksort is one of the
benchmarks people use with test at data
center so some of you may have heard the
story of a pedo sort which is basically
I have this many machines connected I
just use a quick sort of just check
whether I wired them up the correct
weight sort it's also fairly easy to
implement of reasonably efficient
version of quicksort it is about 30
lines of code and empirically the
behavior of quicksort is something like
20 passes over the data I'm using 20 any
are very liberal sense theoretically
it's a n log n time algorithm but the
practical behavior of wall clockwise is
roughly twenty passes over your data I
and I claim that when you compare a
linear system versus quicksort
in these parameters in every one of them
linear systems over as a primitive is
lacking you can't get linear systems
over to be too weak to work in linear
space but sometimes you but there you
also lose a bidding time but
the majority of the linear system
command solving commands we have things
like backslash this is something a big
super linear space but that's that's a
direct so far right I mean depending on
if you have iterative metrics and a
different converting properties
depending on the norms and or I guess
you're talking about a direct message
them things that we can just invoke and
say one line command right so quicksort
I mean there are also other variants as
well that right now if you go to MATLAB
you invoke backslash on something with
about ten to eight nonzero rows that
will basically the first thing that will
chapter halt is that your computer will
run out of memory so I'm really talking
about this English sense of what can you
invoke and what can we just take say
download snap and what can we run them
off with some work you can make space
linear but then here they're also issue
uh parallelizable there's that your
trade-off right if you go to iterative
methods iterative methods are not as
parallel as a direct method in lines of
code right when you invoke that lab heck
if you invoke backslash the number of
lines of C++ are getting vote is
something like 10 to the 4 lines of code
and also if you look at runtime the
runtime question mark because for
summing senses they run really well for
some instances there is a significant
slowdown in fact I will talk about the
and this runtime the way to describe it
is that we we can actually solve some
linear systems really well so this is a
very this plot to me was very
interesting what we did is we took one
of these methods so this is a convex
optimization outward this is in Curie
point method we invoked linear system
solvers disease are basically things
like Jacobi iteration Gauss Seidel
incomplete Lu factorization MSD
pre-conditioner algebraic multigrid so
these are some very standard benchmarks
they were invoked from the trial in
those package from Sandia now what we
did is we ran them by interior point
method and when we plotted at PI so this
is D preconditioners Jacobi yeah we we
knew some insight of PCG we use these
inside precondition hundred gradient
inside an interior point of Google so
what we did is we took a second-order
method and then we at every iteration we
solve the linear system
and then we measured how long that
linear system self took and what the
interesting here is that on the first
iteration they all ran really well oh by
the way we also took him really hard
instance which is a 50-50 by 50 by 50
cube grid those of you familiar with
graph algorithms or familiar with to say
like this guy max the data set the 50 by
50 by 50 cube this is one of the hardest
instances for graph algorithms so so the
interesting thing is that on the first
situation they all run really well but
then as interior point method kind of
chugs along and start transferring the
it starts generating numerically more
and more difficult problems
these methods their behavior tends to
start going all over the board until
about iteration 25 to 30 where their
behavior is significantly slower than on
the first iteration why that's because
the matrix is becoming singular and the
convergence rate depends on the
condition above the matrix right as the
interior method I guess Michael you can
correct me could gets to the to the bow
or whatever to their boundary of the
active set the matrix becomes more
condition if you had used the backslash
which is just a direct message you
wouldn't have seen any difference so the
issue with the backslash is that it's a
direct method and on this kind of
instance this is already starting
approach the limit conditions that you
see that interior point method and the
readme from the outer loop which is
actually it's exactly the same thing
which is that because of the behavior of
all these fast linear system solvers
sometimes when you depends on a problem
you're running out sometimes you
actually have to invoke a different
solver or sometimes you may even have to
run your code again I mean for this one
the authors of this packages was for the
isotonic regression problem and want the
author Rasmus etching the audience so
I'll I've heard some I mean I'm not
totally familiar with the story but this
is what the readme files days
SGS is a sparse gauss-seidel so
gauss-seidel is I take the matrix and I
take the upper diagonal and a
precondition with that and the MST is
because the the problem here is it has
graph theoretic structure so what you
can do is you can take the matrix and
you may take a max weight spanning tree
and your precondition by that so this is
kind of one this graph theoretic methods
that I'll get to that in a bit as well
but in general the but what this also
means is that actually the hurts being
if you look at the first column though
this is very reassuring in that it says
that we do know how to solve a lot of
the inner systems really well in fact
there has been extensive work on linear
system solving and one indication of
this is that when the Society of
industrial and applied mathematics had
their editors named a top ten algorithms
of the 20th century
three out of ten algorithms are directly
related to solving systems of linear
equations so these are things like
matrix decomposition so this is kind of
like blocking of matrices QR
factorization which there has been
several talks out trial of space methods
which is another one these iterative
methods used to compute eigenvectors
in fact for most natural linear systems
and I completely agree with agree with
you that the example I was showing is a
very adversarial example in that it's
artificially transferring the difficulty
of a combinatorial problem from
combinatorial optimization into the
linear system itself but for most
naturally occurring linear system we
actually have very good solvers in both
MATLAB and Julia when for most systems
of say ten to the six now zeros we can
solve that in a couple of seconds your
solve command does do that in a couple
of seconds but then this leads to the
open question which is that can we do
this prob'ly for all systems of linear
equations and and this is becoming
increasingly important just because how
many situations do we have now of the
where we do need to invoke linear system
solvers I'm sorry can in that in your
example of your conjugate gradient right
which took advantage of the of the
structure of the matrix because it is
symmetric positive-definite matrix while
the backslash Kumar does either ever to
dine you or else it does a QR or maybe
it doesn't have to be deep or depending
on what you have but I mean I guess we
need to distinguish by the that yeah
bubble sixth row at the structure of the
matrix yeah there there is a lot of
layers to how the complexity of one
these work and I will get to the things
you need that right iterative in a
second as well and what I want to talk
about in this talk is I want to talk
about some recent progress being trying
to address this question and the central
role that randomized numerical linear
algebra place in getting all these
pieces to talk to each other and to do
that I need to go through exactly what
you were mentioning which is I need to
talk about what are the current pieces
we have for solving systems of linear
equations
and for this talk I will focus on the
linear case but almost everything I say
I actually have nonlinear extensions and
I will mention that very briefly in the
slide where I introduce these these
concentration bands so there so as your
as you have been saying there are two
main types of ideas for solving systems
of linear equations one of them direct
method this has been this is probably
one the oldest studied algorithms in
that the first descriptions of direct of
direct method probably are all they were
written before they were not really been
waiting Arabic numbers so this is this
example is written in what's called rod
calculus which is kind of earlier system
for denoting numbers and this operation
is essentially I mean they also pivot in
rows in a very weird way they were
taking the last column and they were
using this to cancel this column so the
operation here is I they used this
column to eliminate this nonzero but the
idea direct methods is that they try to
modify my matrix entry by entry until my
matrix gets to a point where it becomes
easy to solve this has led to a lot of
beautiful working areas like sign to
comment or all scientific computing
where one tries to systematically model
the nonzero structure so this is
basically the backslash command this at
least theoretically this kind of ideas
is present in matrix multiplication is
present in parallel graph algorithms
it's also present in things like sparse
if I'd squaring which some of you may
know from log space connectivity
the other type of a key building block
is iterative methods the idea of
iterative method is instead of trying to
modify my matrix so that good things
happen I just try to numerically
converge to a solution I'm sorry why did
you say the direct methods upcoming
tutorial I mean I'm because they try to
physically they don't really look at a
numerical structure of your matrix when
you start combining that I can iterative
like you run in Campeche Olesky inside
PCG that's the point but I consider that
to be a hybrid method in that you're
doing something to the direct you're
doing something to the matrix in a way
that you're also looking at a numerical
structure as well but methods for
example Gauss elimination right also
elimination it says that under exact
arithmetic oh I care about is a
combinatorial structure when you have a
fast direct method solver things like
nested dissection the nest at section
there are result that says as long as my
nonzero structure is planar there's
actually not as much dependence on the
numerical structure compared to say
iterative methods where iterative
methods you're dependent on the eigen
value and eigen structured methods when
we orders the matrix in order to avoid
fill-in the reordering you know a lot of
the a lot of these things are really
kind of building upon this kind of idea
for getting good orderings the
combinatorial sign exactly computing
type ideas for the dense case you are
really looking at things like matrix
multiplication and so on
for the idea of iterative method on the
other hand is I try to gradually
converge to a solution so if the kind of
idea is that
I take I want to solve ax equal to B by
just repeatedly doing this is called
Richardson iteration there there's also
a constant here I'm missing but the
simplest iterative method is literally
at every time I add the residual of my
inner end on to my back it's not a media
that is converges but one thing you can
notice is that the fixed point of this
is basically if ax equal to B so yeah
once I do have convergence right I do
arrive at a solution and the speed of
convergence of an iterative method can
be controlled by instead solved by
introducing what's called a precondition
so there's B inverse and instead of
solving ax equal to B I saw being verse
ax equal to B inverse B I which for in
your inner end becomes
every time I take the residual and I'm
multiply that B inverse and this gives
you a lot more control it gives you room
to start manipulating between the
difficulty of a pre-k of solving a
pre-conditioner and a speed of
convergence so you get to two extremes
why is that if you have a simple B I can
just set B to be identity which case
I'll just need as many iterations at the
um precondition or that I can set B
equal to a in which case out finishing
one iteration but I need to solve the
same problem and the kind of the
intricacy iterative method is all about
finding the right P and this is kind of
one of the key ideas underlying say
counted gradient algorithms convex
optimization things like gradient
descent precondition gradient descent
can also be viewed as another case of
iterative methods and Krylov space
method it's also another very iterative
methods conjugate gradient is a kind of
spirit
yes
and the interesting thing about both of
these methods is that they both have
instances that they do extremely well
and they also both have instances where
they're problematic and it's a way to
the way I could think about the the
scalability of these algorithms is
really using this notion that the way
that comes as high performance computing
does it which is that they think of the
non-zeros graph theoretically there is a
very nice correlation between graphs and
matrices where the non-zeros in your
graph you can think about a bi thing
about every variable as a vertex and
every nonzero because we think some row
and column you can think about as a edge
using a pair of vertices and this kind
of view of your common toriel structure
as a graph it lets you think about the
difficulty of your problem and then here
there are two extreme cases one is that
have a very highly connected problem and
the other extreme I have a long path and
the interesting thing is that for highly
connected instance what I want is I want
to use iterative method I want to take
very global steps because my entire
problem is just a single thing it's very
well connected everything I do is
symmetric I might as well take global
steps and if you start to apply
iterative methods what happens that your
fill just goes to just-just-just it
sounds extreme so paths on the other
hand what you really want to do it
through a path is a direct method is if
you start eliminating from one end of
the path so these things like tri
diagonal matrices if you eliminate from
one end of a path very good things
happen you have zero fill but on the
other hand if you try to propagate
information iteratively on a path right
what happens at every step you can't
talk to your neighbor which means that
the number of iterations you need is
lower bounded by the diameter of your
graph you need it you need one end graph
must talk to the other so we get these
two extreme instances where direct
method good good on what iterative
method is go down the other and vice
versa direct method is bad on this one
iterative method is good on the other is
bad on this one and the biggest problem
with matrices and graphs is that they're
additive I can take any two matrices I
can put them together I got an even more
extreme instance so the difficulty in
getting prob'ly nearly linear time oh
and for this you can essentially think
about it as I want
avoid pain order and iterations given by
the diameter of the graph times the cost
of m per iteration which is what you
need to do a single propagation step if
you take a global step so there's these
two ideas where I want to get what
called hybrid algorithms which is I want
to start putting together direct and
iterative methods in a way where I can
prove leverage the what's from about
each one without running into the bad
case for the other and what the earliest
example of this is basically
preconditioned
sparse cholesky factorization which is
what you have been mentioning is I can
instead of calling toll S key which is
the backslash command I can call PCG
with incomplete role as the inside and
in terms of linear system solving
probably the easiest takeaway is that in
some times instead of using the
backslash I can call this command with a
MATLAB called PCG and the ital inside
and that tends to work for matrices
that's about a factor 10 20 bigger and
but of course the issue with the reason
MATLAB doesn't use that as default solve
command is that because this depends on
numerical structure it leads to some
fairly easy situations sometimes so the
backslash is the more dependable command
and the next step in this kind of hybrid
algorithm was taken by by G and what my
job was what really motivated to do this
was he was really studying in cure point
methods but applied to the minimum cost
flow problem so he was looking at the
Hessian matrix of the interior point
method applied to a min Castro and multi
commodity flow problems and he started
saying that because my problem is
related to a graph what I want to do is
I'm on a precondition my graph with a
graph as well and I want to analyze the
approximation ratio between these using
graph theoretic techniques so what are
you really advocated was this very tight
coupling between the combinatorial and
numerical algorithms at least to some
fairly absurd statement like what the
relative condition number between a pair
of brats or what is the diameter of a
matrix or
what is the average clustering
coefficient or the centrality of a
matrix and what this leads to is a leads
to the I mean what this R is really
eventually resulting is a resulting
statement somewhat absurd to both graph
opportunists as well as numerical
analysts but from a perspective what
this seems to be doing is that there are
actually several ways to make sense of
this what is that
you're viewing the numerical operator as
another resource of error and you're
just controlling this kind of operator
error as another album resource the same
way that you would control say the size
of your problem or say the amortized
potential of your data structures so
it's just another form of convergence
error or another parameter in designing
an algorithm and the other idea that
this really led to is this very
fine-grained coupling between
combinatorial and numerical tools in
these algorithms and and to do this we
really need to start specifying what is
the numerical structure of my matrices
and here the starting point which is and
this is one of the simplest cases where
my matrix had both graph theoretic and
good numerical structure is what's
called a graph laplacian matrix these
are related to M matrices and the idea
is that I can take a graph I can write
down a matrix where it's a adjacency
matrix but I take the diagonal with the
degrees and I subtract away the
adjacency matrix these are obvious
central to spectral algorithms which is
why a lot of the earlier results in this
area actually went through spectral
graph theory it comes up naturally in
inference on graphs and the application
motivate demoted but the motivate
advisor to think about them is that it's
related to the Hessian of interior point
algorithms this led to a lot of work and
the work that really caused this area to
take off is this result by Spearman 10
who stated that any graph laplacian
can be properly solved in nearly linear
time what is nearly linear mean it also
means that something comically bad it
means about M times log log into the
power of 70
but then once the kind of the cool thing
about theory is that one Java once you
have indication that might be a oven in
some space then we can keep on working
out we can keep on whittling away at the
parameters so the this led to
essentially a hacking of this parameter
every two years and then let's wait to
log in log squared and and then went to
log in and when this logon came out we
start asking is this just another case
of Zeno's paradox which is that I if I
try to run towards the end goal which is
get linear time algorithms do I just
always just have my distance to it and
unfortunate became a self-fulfilling
prophecy in that we actually came up
with a M square root log n time
algorithm but the other thing that's
really exciting about this is also
people figure out how to how to take
these ideas to the nonlinear set in a
nonlinear setting you can write down
this kind of optimization problem
involving the edge vertex incidence
matrix of a graph which is what I'll get
to and here you people started improving
over fundamental result in combinatorial
optimization things like max-flow
min-cut flow bipartite matching matrix
rescaling basically these are all
improve have been all been improved over
the last ten years shortened and the
other thing is that now there have been
several code packages the most the most
comprehensive this is actually being
maintained in Julia it's called
laplacian jl and this has things like
effective resistance spectral clustering
eigenvalues has a whole bunch of nice
things and I and I had urge you to check
it out but I want to talk about is the
kind of the core ideas that have really
developed in this in this in this kind
of area which seeks to integrate
combinatorial and numerical algorithms
and here there really have been two
kinds of ideas what is this really this
kind of original picture by by Jeff
which is I gradually take my graph and I
convert it to things that more tree like
and then there's a more recent one where
which instead turning our graphing to a
tree we try to turn a graph into a
clique so we try to just take Gauss
elimination and we try to speed up some
kind of elimination based out
and the way that to summarize what these
are doing is that there is really two
type of methods called ultra sparsa fire
and elimination where the goal of ultras
part suffocation it's really motive a
motivated by travel with them which are
really based on trees so what it seeks
to do is it seeks to gradually remove
edges and then make my object more tree
like the other hand the elimination
based algorithms it's really motivated
by Gaussian elimination and what it
seeks to do is they seeks to get rid of
a lot of edges so he seeks to do Gauss
elimination but in a way that has access
to a numerical structure and uses the
numerical structure to provably
keep everything intermediate sparse as
well as having small error against the
original object so the idea there is
that I want to work on the condition
number of the matrix and I incur small
error but I try to make a fact or two
reduction condition number every time so
this has been recently there is a work
by Rasmussen Shoshanna scrolls different
clothes that the NTU factors have a
condition number is larger than that of
the original matrix that's obsessed by
exhibiting course elimination so I'm
talking about that's focused on graph
laplacian and graph laplacian because
they're symmetric matrices what you can
do is that because it's symmetric every
time you get rid of a row you get rid of
the corresponding column as well this is
really for graph laplacian these both of
these albums are really geared towards
graph laplacian is nothing else okay
yeah I will get to the more general case
in a later slide as well so they buy the
core idea in these algorithms is that I
want to do this very gradual transfer so
notice that I'm taking very fine-grain
trade-offs between my problem difficulty
and my approximation factors I'm trading
a factor K reduction in edges for error
that is K times log squared n I'm
trading a factor to improvement in
condition number for a 1 over log and
error so you get a lot of these very
fine control of error versus problem
size and the key idea that really
enabled this is really this kind of high
dimensional concentration phenomenon
so the key phenomena here is really
dimensionality reduction and here the
there has there have been several very
interesting talks on this phenomenon
about sampling from large matrices and
the way that I really like to think
about this phenomena is really through
this result called baaaack spacing
beddings which states that there's a
this is a real element this is the way
of the function this is a way of
functional analysis things about the
world in that for any function f i can
take a matrix a and i think about a
Banach space that is f of a X and the
kind of fundamental result in Banach
spaces is that for any n-dimensional
Banach space has an embedding into a
space that is roughly size dimension x
log and over epsilon squared and here
the result is really phrased in terms of
norms and what are those you're from it
basically the four norms you just take
every entry of your back turn you take
through some power and you take the one
over P root of the whole thing
but I will make it what this kind of
embedding result is really saying is
that if I have a matrix with many more
rows than columns I can subsample a set
of rows in a way that I wouldn't likely
I preserve the operator structure and
the way that this can be used is that as
long as I have this kind of space
approximation what you can show is that
any optimization problem you're solving
on the original matrix it's okay to
solve it on the sample matrix so you can
actually just transfer your error
directly you can transfer your problem
directly from a matrix with many roasts
to immeasurably few rows and this kind
of statement is crucial for this kind of
trading between combinatorial and
numerical difficulty because it's a
statement that says I can get rid of
rows but of my matrix in a way that I
completely preserved a numerical
structure so one end of it is completely
combinatorial the other side is
completely numerical linear right some
kind of lectures condition
I'm actually not sure how general f can
be so it this definitely works for every
norm so it works for Euclidean distance
it works for one norm it works for say
four norm as well there's some
dependency on the function I'm not
familiar with what is the extent which
this can be done and to discuss how this
works on graphs I do need to introduce
one more object which is the edge vertex
incidence matrix just like the graph
laplacian this is another object and you
can write another matrix that you can
write down from a crack in that what you
do is you take one row for every edge
and you put a minus 1 and a 1 in it's
two endpoints and and the reason I like
this matrix is that this really drives
home the point why I want an
approximation in the BX 2 norm space in
that if you think about a vector that is
plus 1 and some vertices minus 1 some
other vertices or just one on some
vertices 0 somewhere else for a single
edge what that will give you is it gives
you X u minus X V squared so if you let
X be a subset of vertices in a graph
then px 2 norm what it gives you is
exactly how many edges leave that subset
of vertices this gives you graph cuts
with a little bit more working I also
show that if you approximate be B
transpose B because I always the is the
grand matrix of B what do you actually
can get is you can get this kind of
approximation in laplacian matrices what
so what this implies is that any
undirected graph have a sparse
approximation and well and the point I
would like to stress about this kind of
statement what's really important about
this kind of statement is say that I'm
approximating an undirected graph by
another undirected graph so so far we
have talked a lot about applying
randomized numerical tools to matrices
but we're not talking about structuring
the output what's really crucial about
this kind of method is that it's very
important for the output of a man matrix
to also be structured and the way that
this gets use our is illustrate this on
the next slide which is that the way you
can incorporate it into an algorithm is
you can take this reduction from matrix
multiplication to linear system solving
this is objects
your compliment which is what happens if
you take a matrix you take a subset of
variables which I call F and I eliminate
and here there's a result by strass it
so the show compound is given by this
formula here and here there's a result
by Strassen from this a key from the
first fast matrix multiplication result
that says as long as I can solve on the
original block and I can solve on the
throw compliment I can solve on the
whole thing this is basically block
elimination but the interesting thing
that happens here is that because my
original matrix is a graph you can
actually prove that your throw
complement is also a graph so now you
can actually go explicitly control the
density of all your intermediate
matrices you can directly go and sparse
it by this object and only work with
sparse matrices during every
intermediate step and you're always and
this is how they nearly what this is my
favorite one slight explanation of how a
nearly linear in time laplacian solver
works it's just that you use the fact
that as you eliminate uncertain
well-structured classes of matrices the
intermediate objects also stay well
structured and the key idea there is
then you have to think through how to
efficiently get all these objects here
you get a bit of a funny chicken egg
problem in that you don't even want to
construct the dance for what but you
want to still manipulate it and here
basically everyone's favorite
algorithmic tools can be applied if you
can do things like sketching you can do
things like spanners data structures
matrix martingales and my favorite
recursion due to interest of time I'll
skip how these algorithms work but a lot
of things do do come into play here you
can also a limit you take things take
things to eliminate more things you can
get to this kind of matrices that come
up from scientific computing these kind
of linear elasticity problems you can
generalize and one thing that becomes
very interesting here is that these
problems actually turn out to be
complete you know you can actually show
that for any positive semi-definite
matrix this is a result by Rasmus King
and pawn shop what they showed is that
actually any PSD matrix can be written
as the intermediate state eliminated
state about two commodity flow matrix
so instead of having a single label
every vertex of or I think a graph
Laplace have two labels this actor turns
out to be complete for everything so
this actually gives you one of the
approaches to actually address all
general matrices is what I'll be kind of
the even more absurd side the other
thing kind of cut you can kind of do
from this and you can actually design
grasp Arsuf ocation for directed graphs
in that for diabetic are they actually
if you think in terms of operators
unless you think I wouldn't agree you
had to come up with a lot of counter
examples but one way to actually design
this is you actually reverse engineer
from iterative methods of a way for
diabetic approximate each other and I'll
finish off with some open question in
future directions I think so kind of was
a really interesting thing coming out of
here is that we actually by thinking
about these algorithms we're actually
getting at some of these different
notions of approximations and operate
our approximations can we generalize
matrix concentration bound to them can
we take some of these ideas to nonlinear
cases what's the extent to which these
ideas can be taken to nonlinear cases
and there's kind of adaptive sampling to
do they have this kind of dynamic and
streaming applications and I'll finish
off with a chart which is that these are
all the properties with one for direct
methods these are all properties we have
for iterative methods and the claim is
that by combining them in the right way
in hybrid method we can probably get the
best of both in approval manner
stop your and any questions
[Applause]
question
so if you suggest to kind of wrap
everything back together again
it is their dessert like just see if I
understand dessert is there at least a
class of problems where if you want to
solve this do the backslash you give
something that looks like the sorting
properties you get so the currently so
empirically how close are we to getting
those kind of numbers so right now so
the situation with graph laplacian is
that graph laplacian it's also a class
of problems where in scientific
computing there are package that work
really well for them so there are things
like multi grid methods so there's one
package called lean algebraic multigrid
that also that's very well currently the
clock time for these is some there is
something on ten to the seven edges Ling
algebraic multiverse doing about twenty
seconds the lab haciendo JL or like the
combinatorial multi great stuff by Yanis
these things do about somewhere in that
ballpark as well so we're at a point
where in a mid we can get to somewhere
between ten to the seven and ten to the
eight at this point and compared to
sorting we're if you're familiar with
the performance of sorting you can sort
about a billion numbers so we're off by
at least a factor of ten but we're also
soaking in doing significantly better
than the quadratic time running bounds
that you would infer from just the
theoretical bounds for matrix algorithms
as well
so I like to go back to your comments
where you're talking about you know even
between when you're I mean if I
understand it correctly you're saying
that if I'm doing some sort of iterative
process I'd like to go back in examining
sort of a structure internal graph
structure as long as there is some
preservation of grab structure that
inform a good hybrid arbors of the
design it that where the sort of key
takeaway so being both of these organs
what is particularly important is that
I'm repeatedly applying these randomized
tools and for for me to be able to apply
these randomized tools I'm using very
heavily structure of my problem
so one thing actually that's very
problematic about Gauss elimination is
that if for more general systems it
actually tends to get rid of a lot of
structure so generally for things that's
not graph laplacian what you get is you
get it's very high low rank updates and
low rank updates are bad because the
only thing that you can approximate low
rank object with like a rank one matrix
the Archaea spectra approximate is
itself so the quite sort of one thing
that's actually very interesting here is
is there a way to do this kind of
concentration in a way that you don't
have to basically do like for all
vectors so this is where i talk about
are there generalizations by
generalization also means some kind of
restriction so things like contractions
maybe that's actually a very powerful
thing so this here's I think there's a
lot that one can learn from multi grid
algorithms for what are the other way to
keep everything structured it's because
the way that multi grid really does
things is that they they really they
start from the goal I want to engineer
awkward so they come up with a lot of
methods that where they do keep all the
things
intermediately structured and but here
what the issue is we're kind of saying
approvable envelope so we're using
fairly crude ideas coming out of Gauss
elimination
the previous slide it seems to have
quite a profound result where I said the
one way you say that the matrix is
always talking about the truss hardness
oh the truss hardness result oh this one
so say said trusts are complete for all
matrices this is a theorem by Erasmus
endochondral actually explain what this
is really saying is so the problem that
we're that we were addressing this
actually came out of trying to study
what a generalization brothel of Plassey
ins called 2d trusses what 2d trusses
are is that they're related this kind of
physical simulation problem where you're
pointing to dimensions and the instead
of laplace evil posses are really spring
systems 2d trusses what it is is that
every vertex has a position two
dimension space and then your edges are
basically is kind of stress and strain
measuring the vector sense in two
dimensions so you can think of these
things as Laplace Ian's with instead of
one label on vertex every label every
part has two labels and the statement so
what we originally started off doing is
we try to get better algorithm for this
so we try to beat this kind of method by
section of type algorithms but then one
thing that Rasmus and pound what they
realized is that if you are allowed any
kind of structure so if you're a lot of
build an arbitrary trust in particular
one that does not have good geometric
that not have good geometric embedding
you can actually encode any system of
linear equations
as one of these two-dimensional trusses
so this is a very interesting statement
in that exactly ghost article
classifying all the many classes of
structure linear systems and you can
actually show that some of these so for
example to commodity flow that they are
actually complete in the sense that if
you can solve you have a faster solver
for to commodity flow you have a fast
solver for everything and this actually
mean led to various degrees of optimism
in that there's one degree which is that
we think that you can a lot of these
problems you can start classifying the
importance of geometry the important
having embeddings in getting faster I
wouldn't maybe you can prove that there
are problems where if you have geometry
you can do better if you don't have
drawn for you you can't you just can't
do anything the the most extreme sense
of optimism is actually that if you set
up the right notion of what is a meet
doesn't mean to be a general PSD matrix
maybe you can actually use some of these
graph theoretic techniques to get better
out win for all PSD matrices but it that
will probably require a fairly different
notion what does it mean to be like how
to increment encoder the numerical
complexity I want these problems as well
okay let's thank you for joining
[Applause]